La guerra de Ucrania nos ha hecho acostumbrarnos
a escuchar noticias sobre las sanciones y los
bloqueos de activos financieros, yates,
aviones, propiedades inmobiliarias,
y un sin fin de riquezas de toda
índole en manos de los oligarcas rusos.
Ahora bien, ¿Qué conocemos exactamente como
un oligarca? ¿Son ellos los auténticos dueños
de Rusia? ¿Los mandamases en la sombra?
¿Hasta dónde llega su poder? ¿Quienes son?
Estoy seguro de que muchos al escuchar
el término “oligarcas rusos” pensáis en
millonarios con mucho poder. Y sí, simplificando
las cosas podríamos decir que son algo así.
Sin embargo, esa misma definición
podría aplicarse, por ejemplo,
a muchos multimillonarios norteamericanos.
Sin ir más lejos, ahí está el caso de Donald
Trump. Un multimillonario que llegó a ocupar
el puesto de poder más importante de los Estado
Unidos de América y quizás de todo el mundo.
Pero evidentemente Trump no es un oligarca
y sería un error etiquetarlo de esa forma.
Queridos amigos, amigas. En este vídeo
os vamos a contar cómo funciona el
sistema política ruso en la sombra,
quienes son los auténticos dueños
de Rusia y cómo son las relaciones
entre el Kremlin y los oligarcas.
Atentos.
Desde que Vladimir Putin desató su tormenta de
fuego, destrucción y aniquilación sobre Ucrania,
hemos hablado mucho de oligarcas. Pero,
¿Qué es exactamente un oligarca? Creo,
amigos, que esta es la primera
pregunta que tenemos que responder.
Pues bien, los oligarcas rusos
son empresarios extremadamente
ricos cuyas fortunas y negocios dependen
esencialmente de cuán próximos sean al Kremlin.
(Los oligarcas rusos se han convertido
en algo así como la guardia pretoriana
del poder político. La extensión, los brazos
políticos del Kremlin en el terreno económico.
Porque la economía rusa es algo
así como una economía cerrada
y centralizada dónde los funcionarios y
los burócratas han sido sustituidos por
empresarios rentistas que se abren paso a
golpe de influencia, coacción o sobornos.
En la Rusia actual no opera un modelo
capitalista ni tampoco uno de corte
socialista. La Rusia de Putin es algo
así como la viva representación de un
mercantilismo de camarilla moderno. Un modelo
dónde las grandes empresas reciben todo tipo
de privilegio del poder político a cambio
de respaldarlo y seguir sus directrices.
Por tanto, en este país, la relación
entre riqueza privada y poder público
es muy estrecha. Los oligarcas dirigen
y controlan sectores estratégicos para
los intereses de Moscú, como, por
ejemplo, la energía o la defensa.)
Ahora bien, ¿cómo se materializa todo esto en la
práctica? ¿Es esto algo nuevo,
de la Rusia de Vladimir Putin?
Pues lo cierto es que no. De hecho,
podríamos decir que como mínimo ya vamos por
la segunda generación de oligarcas rusos.
Porque, amigos, la primera generación surgió
del caótico proceso de privatizaciones que el
país experimentó durante los años
90, cuando el estado ruso vendió
a coste de saldo muchas de las grandes
empresas públicas de la era soviética.
Fue un proceso atestado de corrupción
que tuvo como referencia los esquemas
de préstamos por acciones. Un sistema que
utilizó las acciones de grandes empresas
públicas de recursos naturales como una especie
de aval de préstamos para el gobierno federal.
Y como el gobierno federal no devolvió
esos préstamos - de forma sospechosamente
intencionada - entonces los acreedores, que
eran magnates y personajes cercanos al poder,
subastaron esas acciones para recuperar
sus préstamos. Subastas, por supuesto,
opacas y amañadas dónde ellos mismos se
presentaban como los únicos compradores.
Y así es como nacieron los oligarcas
y cómo estos tomaron el control de
las grandes empresas del país. De esta forma
los funcionarios y burócratas públicos fueron
sustituidos por estos nuevos “empresarios”. Del
socialismo se pasó al mercantilismo de camarilla.
Todo este proceso se produjo durante
la era de Yeltsin, pero en realidad la
época de Putin no ha sido muy diferente.
Si acaso una evolución de este sistema.
(Yeltsin y Putin eran personajes antagónicos que,
además y a pesar de sus lazos políticos,
se llevaban falta. Y, por supuesto,
cada uno contaba con sus propios grupos de
influencia, que en la práctica eran adversarios.
Así que con Putín llegó la segunda generación
de oligarcas. Su entorno fue abriéndose paso a
través de generosos contratos, concesiones
y permisos del gobierno para explotar las
riquezas del país o supuestamente desarrollar
la industria nacional. De esta forma poco
a poco fueron ocupando los peldaños más
altos de la estructura económica rusa.)
Sí, puede que os sorprenda, pero
el mercantilismo de camarilla de
Rusia no funciona de forma muy
diferente a los grupos mafiosos.
De hecho, el presidente ruso es todo un
especialista en quitarse de en medio a
cualquier persona que le incomode, por ejemplo,
dirigiendo campañas “contra la corrupción”.
Ahí está por ejemplo el caso de Mikhail
Khodorkovsky [PRON: Mijail Jodorkovsky],
un oligarca muy próximo a Yeltsin y una
de las mayores fortunas de Rusia que
fue encarcelado en 2003 bajo acusaciones de
corrupción. Khodorkovsky era el propietario
de la petrolera rusa Yukos, empresa que
le fue expropiada por el gobierno ruso.
(26 de octubre de 2003. Policía en Rusia
captura a magnate petrolero - The New York Times
El hombre más rico de Rusia, el barón del
petróleo Mikhail B. Khodorkovsky, Mijail
Jodorkovsky fue capturado a punta
de pistola el sábado por agentes de
seguridad del gobierno y encarcelado bajo
cargos de fraude y evasión de impuestos.
Sí, puede que todas esas acusaciones fueran
ciertas, pero desde luego no eran algo
excepcional. La corrupción forma parte necesaria
del modelo político imperante en el país.
Esta operación en el año 2003 contra
la mayor fortuna de Rusia fue el primer
disparo de advertencia de Putin a los oligarcas:
Algo así como, Ojo, mucho ojo. Si queréis ir
por libre sufriréis las consecuencias. Estáis
ahí gracias al poder político, así que si no
sois completamente leales lo pagareis muy caro.
Es decir, aquí no hablamos de empresarios que
compiten entre sí y asumen riesgos. Para nada,
el modelo mercantilista ruso sustituye
la competencia por los tratos de favor,
el tráfico de influencias, los sobornos
y las corruptelas de todo tipo.
Los oligarcas a cambio de sus fortunas adquieren
el compromiso de mantener la estabilidad,
la lealtad al poder político e intentar
llevar sus empresas lo mejor posible,
al menos mejor que los resultados
que cosechaban cuándo eran públicas.
Pero, ahora que sabemos qué es exactamente un
oligarca y por qué se habla tanto de ellos,
la pregunta es: ¿Quienes
son exactamente los dueños
de Rusia? ¿Qué cambios trajo consigo
Vladimir Putin? ¿Hasta dónde alcanza
la influencia del presidente ruso
sobre las grandes empresas del país?
Pues bien, veámoslo.
(LOS ACCIONISTAS DE RUSIA)
El modelo oligárquico ruso,
tal y como os hemos contado,
ha pasado fundamentalmente por dos
etapas: la de Yelstin y la de Putin.
La primera se caracterizó por el enorme
poder político que cosecharon algunos
oligarcas. En algunas ocasiones, incluso,
le dictaban al gobierno el rumbo de sus
políticas o llegaron a convertirse en
miembros del gabinete o del gobierno.
Sin embargo, en la segunda etapa, esta situación
cambió radicalmente. Putin estableció a golpe
de puño unas relaciones muy diferentes: los
oligarcas ya no interferirían ni condicionarían
al gobierno. El poder de Rusia está en el
Kremlin, no en las sedes de estas compañías.
(De esta forma Putín impulso normas y
leyes para que los grandes oligarcas de
las industrias estratégicas como la energía,
la minería o los medios de comunicación,
le vendieran parte de sus acciones al
Estado o a entidades controladas por este.
La idea era estrechar mucho más los lazos entre
el Kremlin y las grandes corporaciones rusas.
Y así es como nacieron las llamadas
corporaciones estatales a las que
Putin blindó legalmente con tratos
preferentes y privilegios de todo tipo.
Se estima que estas corporaciones controlan
hoy el 55% de la economía rusa. Es toda una
variante del capitalismo de Estado que le ha
dado a Putin un control sin precedentes sobre
los sectores productivos más importantes
del país y también sobre sus dueños.)
Es decir, en la práctica a diferencia de la era
Yeltsin los oligarcas rusos ya no se limitan a
ser los propietarios de grandes conglomerados
industriales, sino sobre todo los responsables
de gestionar estos grupos en nombre del Kremlin.
De esta forma los sobornos y las rentas que se
extraen de estas grandes empresas alcanzan
a todos los resortes del poder del país.
Ese es el gran cambio que se ha producido
y lo que ha dado a Vladimir Putin un poder
sin precedentes. Y esto es también lo que
explica que a pesar de todas las sanciones
internacionales que Rusia está sufriendo tras
la invasión de Ucrania, los oligarcas apenas se
hayan pronunciado. Porque ahora ellos dependen
de Putin más de lo que Putin depende de ellos.
Por supuesto, este sistema conlleva unos niveles
de productividad, innovación y competitividad muy
pobres, pero…garantiza una estabilidad enorme para
todas las partes, excepto, claro está, para la
inmensa mayoría de los rusos.
Pero dicho esto hay una pregunta
en el aire, ¿Quiénes son exactamente
los principales oligarcas del país?
(LOS “AMIGOS” DEL KREMLIN)
Actualmente en Rusia podemos
encontrar 3 tipos de oligarcas.
Primero están los amigos de Putin, que son los
que están conectados en el terreno personal
con el presidente, su círculo más próximo.
Hablamos, por ejemplo, de antiguos amigos
de San Petersburgo, de donde procede el
presidente ruso, o ex-compañeros de la KGB.
Luego están los líderes de los
servicios de seguridad, FSB,
la policía y el ejército, que
son conocidos como ‘Siloviki’.
Y por último tenemos a los outsiders.
Pues bien, respecto a los primeros,
se trata de un grupo de personas que,
literalmente, le deben a Putin todo. Personas
que han logrado multiplicar su riqueza hasta
niveles inimaginables desde que Putin llegó
al poder. Son los fieles entre los fieles.
(Ahí tenemos por ejemplo el caso de Yuri
Kovalchuk, conocido como el banquero
personal de Putin y que amasa una fortuna
de 1.700 millones de dólares. Actualmente
es el principal accionista de Rossiya Bank,
uno de los bancos más importantes del país.
Pero si esto os parece mucho dinero, atentos al
caso Leonid Mikhelson [PRON: Leonid Mijelson],
otro amigo personal del presidente ruso. Mikhelson
cuenta con una fortuna estimada en 18.100 millones
de dólares, y ocupa actualmente el número 66 entre
las personas más ricas del mundo según Forbes.
Mikhelson es fundador y director de
Novatek, una empresa de gas natural,
que actualmente está sancionada por Occidente,
precisamente por sus vínculos con el Kremlin.)
Luego, otro amigo personal del
presidente, Gennadiy Timchenko,
ha logrado amasar una fortuna de 15.700
millones de dólares a través del Grupo Volga,
su empresa de inversión mediante la que invierte
en corporaciones controladas por otros oligarcas.
Luego, por el lado de los Siloviki, de los
oligarcas que proceden de los servicios de
seguridad y demás, tenemos el ejemplo de
Igor Sechin, que ahora es presidente de
la petrolera rusa Rosneft pero que en los
80 era un espía soviético en Mozambique,
aunque oficialmente su actividad
era la de ser un mero “traductor”.
Putin entendió muy pronto que tener
el control pleno de los servicios
de seguridad y hacerse con la lealtad
absoluta de sus líderes resultaba un
paso clave para consolidar su poder. Así
que los enriqueció de forma desmesurada.
Y luego finalmente por el lado de
los outsiders tenemos a una serie
de hombres que lograron salvarse de la purga de
oligarcas que Putin hizo tras la era Yeltsin.
(Uno de ellos es Vladimir Potanin, que
se benefició del esquema de préstamos
por acciones de Yeltsin hasta amasar a día de
hoy una fortuna de 16.500 millones de dólares.
Potanin es propietario del 30% de Norilsk
Nickel, una importante empresa minera, así como
participaciones en empresas de seguros, medios
de comunicación, petróleo, y un largo etcétera.)
Ya lo véis, en Rusia las fortunas no se construyen
por ingenio empresarial sino sobre todo por
influencias con el Kremlin. Y ojo porque no
hablamos de fortunas precisamente menores.
Los grandes millonarios rusos,
acumulan un patrimonio que se
valora entre los 400 y los
800 mil millones de dólares.
Ya lo véis, en Rusia las fortunas no se construyen
por ingenio empresarial sino sobre todo por
influencias con el Kremlin. Y ojo porque no
hablamos de fortunas precisamente menores.
Los grandes millonarios rusos, acumulan
un patrimonio que se valora entre los
400 y los 800 mil millones de dólares.
El problema es que este modelo permite
hacer funcionar empresas básicas pero no
desarrollar negocios demasiado complejos.
Y ese es exactamente uno de
los mayores problemas de Rusia:
el país ha sido incapaz de ser algo
más que un mero exportador de recursos
naturales. Y luego la corrupción ahoga
cualquier posible evolución. Esto es
lo que explica que Rusia sea uno de los
países más desiguales y menos prósperos.
Por supuesto el incentivo de los grandes oligarcas
rusos pasa por ser incondicionales al Kremlin,
vivir la vida y convertirse en embajadores
de Moscú en las plazas más ricas del mundo.
Claro que ahora las sanciones,
les están golpeando duro.
Como veis golpear a los grandes oligarcas equivale
a golpear al estado ruso. Por eso los aliados les
han puesto en la diana. También esperan que una
presión suficiente pueda llegar incluso a provocar
un movimiento de sillas en Moscú. Al fin y al cabo
se confía en que nadie quiera perder su estatus.
Todo esto explica por qué muchos
países están sancionando a los
oligarcas incluso con más ímpetu que
a otras instituciones rusas. Fijaos:
De momento, tal y como ya os contamos en un pasado
boletín de Patreon. Los oligarcas rusos
están buscando refugio en lugares como
Dubái. A la hora de la verdad ellos son
quizás los que menos se fían de Putin.
Por cierto, si queréis recibir nuestro boletín,
las Claves de la Semana, no tenéis más que
sumaros a nuestra comunidad de Patreon.
Con vuestra ayuda podremos hacer crecer
aún más esté proyecto y crear más y mejor
contenido independiente. Por el camino además de
las Claves de la semana podréis recibir, también
Latampolitik, contenido exclusivo y merchandising
único. Os dejamos el link en la descripción.
Pero dicho esto, turno para ti: ¿crees que
las sanciones conducirán a los oligarcas a
traicionar a Putin? ¿Qué os parece este especie
de mercantilismo de camarilla que gobierna
Rusia? ¿Deben los gobiernos occidentales
perseguir sin tregua a los oligarcas rusos?
Déjanos por aquí abajo tus impresiones.
Y ahora si este vídeo os ha resultado
interesante no olvidéis darle a
like y suscribiros a VisualPolitik.